if you're writing about people you have
to be
interested in people
what makes a question a good question
well i like a question like do your
children shower who's the drunkest
customer that you've had today i met
this woman one time and i said when was
the last time you touched a monkey
and she said oh can you smell it on me
in this class i'll talk about connecting
with people and
asking them questions i'll talk about
keeping a diary it begins with a
notebook
i'll be reading a few of my published
essays lisa you're a natural
i'm often asked what does your family
feel when you write about them well i
thought i would bring my sister lisa
here
and find out from her
i go willingly to my desk every morning
and write in my diary
i write something over probably 12 to 18
times
writing is rewriting and when you read
in front of an audience and i'll make
notes and i'll rewrite it
read it rewrite it read it rewrite it to
get an idea of the overall
rhythm the danger is writing something
that just stops
instead of something that ends a huge
part of writing is learning to trust
yourself and that just comes with
experience
i wrote every day for 15 years before my
first book came out
most of the writers that i know have
similar stories
write something that stinks try and fail
failure is fantastic don't underestimate
failure
you have to connect with people on some
level and it's good to
pay attention and keep a diary because
every now and then your life feels like
a story
it's exciting to think that you're
living in this world with all these
other people and today is an opportunity
for you to connect with some of them
that's makes life worth living i'm david
sedaris and this
is my master class
[Music]
you